membre de saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2016
onze mille habitants villepreux devrait
compter un nouveau quartier à l'horizon
après plusieurs mois de concertation le
projet central park avait été dévoilée
fin 2018
objectif créer une entrée de ville
urbaine et paysagère scénario choisi
pour l'aménagement du secteur élargi du
trianon 250 logements et un grand parc
urbain de 19 mille mètres carrés selon
le calendrier annoncé les travaux
devraient débuter en 2020 un projet que
souhaite voir gelée plusieurs candidats
autre thème qui s'invite dans la
campagne la santé ville prenez pas un
désert médical mais il situé dans une
zone d'action complémentaires selon la
rs la diminution du nombre de praticiens
en raison notamment des départs à la
retraite inquiète les habitants une
offre de soins jugé insuffisante qui
pourrait être étoffée avec la création
d'une maison de santé
autre enjeu la redynamisation du
centre-ville et notamment le
développement des commerces de proximité
qui souffrent de la concurrence des
zones commerciales des villes voisines
de plaisir et des clayes-sous-bois enfin
quel avenir pour le théâtre de
villepreux l'établissement culturel de
400 places ne propose plus de spectacle
depuis septembre dernier plusieurs
candidats souhaitent re développer la
culture dans la ville et notamment
réhabiliter cet espace